لقد تحدثت مع وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
أمس ماذا قال لك
أين هو في هذه اللحظة ،
انظر جيدًا كما تعلم وصلت إليه في موقعه
أقصد أننا وصفناه بأنه ملجأ محصن في مكان
غير معلن عنه ولكن مع ذلك
في كييف بأوكرانيا أه للتحدث معه
حول الكيفية التي رأى بها هذا الأمر
وبالطبع مع استمرار أه الاستهداف المتزايد
للمدنيين وما
قاله كان في الواقع مثيرًا للاهتمام
لأنه قال إنه تحدث إلى
وزير الخارجية الصيني
نظيره وهذا مهم حقًا لأن
الصينيين هم  تذكر الصور الشهيرة
في بداية الألعاب الأولمبية عندما أعلن
الرئيس الحادي عشر وبوتين بشكل أساسي
أن أي شيء غير محظور يسير على ما
يرام الآن ،
لقد تحول الصينيون بالفعل منذ هذا
الغزو ومنذ استهداف
المدنيين وحتى ذكروا
المدنيين وأفرادهم.  قلق
بشأن المدنيين ودعوك تعلم
أن هذا مصدر قلق كبير وقد
عرضوا المساعدة في أي نوع من
إزالة التصعيد  ن هذا ما
قاله لي وزير الخارجية الأوكراني كوليبة
إنه أكد لي أن
الصين غير مهتمة بهذه الحرب
ومستعدة للبحث عن حل سلمي
لهذا الصراع أه من خلال الدبلوماسية
لذلك ناشدت أه وزير الخارجية الصيني
وكذلك الخارجية الهندية
وزير
للاستفادة من نفوذهم على بوتين
لعلاقاتهم مع روسيا وحث بوتين على
وقف هذه الحرب على
الفور مرة أخرى مهم جدًا لأنه من
الواضح أن الصين لديها نفوذ كبير
وعلاقة معقدة ضخمة أه مع بوتين
نفسه ، وكذلك تفعل الهند  وأيضًا
ويليام كوهين ، وزير الدفاع الأمريكي السابق ،
قال إن إسرائيل يمكن أن تلعب
دورًا مهمًا في هذا أيضًا ،
وبعبارة أخرى ، تجعل البلدان التي لا
يزال لديها نوع من التأثير أو التأثير
مع بوتين تفعل شيئًا حيال ذلك ، كما أن
كوليبرا تدعو مرة أخرى  على الأمم المتحدة
أن تجرد روسيا من
مقعدها في مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة قائلة إنها
ورثت للتو مقعد الاتحاد السوفيتي القديم ولم
يصوت أحد لصالحه وأن  كان في 91-92